m
à partir du 11 septembre l'artothèque le
saint-denis proposera une exposition
intitulée vue intérieure des portraits
de famille réalisée par françois louis
athénas seuls auteurs réunionnais à
perpétuer la pratique de la photographie
argentique traditionnelle au delà du
portrait de chaque famille ce qui est
proposé d'image en image est un portrait
de la société réunionnaise contemporaine
je vais intérieur abord toutes les
couches sociales tous les groupes
ethniques toutes les dimensions
géographiques de lille alors cette
exposition d'abord c'est un travail
photographique que je mène depuis plus
de cinq ans et il ya vraiment deux
aspects dans cette exposition dans ce
travail photographique
il ya un aspect d'abord c'est un travail
de mémoire c'est un travail qui revisite
la tradition du portrait de famille je
vais chez les gens ils se rassemblent en
famille
alors des fois ils sont seuls des
célibataires des fois c'est des nerfs
avec des enfants le mari d plus la
bourse et des fois son très grande
famille la plus grande famille
photographier effet 23 personnes donc je
vais les voir on prend rendez vous et
tout le monde pose devant les
photographes
moi je ne fais que des photos à
l'ancienne en noir et blanc avec des
films pas des photos numériques donc on
retrouve un petit peu ce 7 po cette
gestuelle qu'on avait sur les photos
qu'on a reçues de nos grands parents
c'est un des premiers volets c'est
vraiment ce travail de mémoire ce
travail de ressusciter la photo de
famille longtemps le deuxième volet bas
c'est le portrait de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'on photographie
show kadhafi les gens chez eux c'est des
gens d'aujourd'hui
il vit dans des cases à terre dans des
cases en l'air on voit le décor on voit
la manière dont tu y vivent ou voient
leurs meubles
ce qui est accroché union voient leur
goût on veut la télévision on voit des
fleurs des choses comme ça et finalement
tous ces portraits nous avons évidemment
c'est le portrait de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'évidemment je
suis allé voir des familles de toutes
origines de toutes conditions sociales
un véritable paysage humain constitué de
visages familiers et connus dont
l'intimité nous apparaît ici révélée est
révélatrice dans cette série de 50
images il est quelques symboles de la
réunion du début du xxième siècle
on va voir bat paul vergès shelly jean
paul virapoullé shelly on va voir daniel
waro qui pour moi était vraiment le le
pilier central de la culture musicale on
va voir charly lesquelin qui est chez
lui donc un peintre on va voir
emmanuel genvrin et rachel potins des
autres des gens de théâtre on va voir
comme ça quelques familles un peu plus
connu que les autres et qui témoigne
aussi de ce qu'est la réunion
d'aujourd'hui dans dans les arts dans la
culture françois louis athéna c'est un
photographe qui travaille à l'ancienne
il n'a pas lâché les pellicules et les
appareils argentiques
dans son atelier continue de développer
ses clichés
un savoir faire qui se perd et une
philosophie qu'il défend alors belz et
des photos fait à l'ancienne je ne
travaille qu'en photographie on appelait
argentique
je suis l'un des derniers à le faire à
la règle
on doit le dernier professionnel
certainement à ne travailler que comme
ça donc toutes les photos qui a dans
cette exposition ils ont été faites avec
un appareil qui est un leica comme si ce
traditionnel sur des pellicules photos
noir et blanc et ensuite les tirages ont
été faits dans mon atelier à
l'agrandisseur dans le révélateur le
mana rennes fixateur à l'ancienne
et voilà je continue à travailler comme
ça toutes ces photographies ont été
faites comme ça et elle procède de la
vieille tradition de la vieille manière
de faire des images photographies
françois-louis athénas choisi avec vue
intérieure de croiser son regard et ses
questionnements avec deux artistes
réunionnais
le plasticien lionel lorette et
l'écrivain jean françois sam lun une
exposition de plusieurs artistes qui
réfléchissent précisément sur le
portrait de la réunion d'aujourd'hui la
vidéo cette exposition c'est
d'accompagner france où l'internet dans
son exposition photo donc en fait son
propos était d'aller chez les gens donc
dans les intérieurs de filmer et les
photographier des familles un travail
qui a duré un besoin certain nombre
d'années et normand vêtement long
travail c'était d'illustrer un peu tout
ça donc de de l'accompagner dans une
démarche où il n'y aurait pas que des
photos dans l'exposition
donc en fait d'ajouter des petits
détails notamment en fait aussi de
recréer un espace derrière l'exposition
étant donné que le thème en fait de
l'exposition est véritablement de
photographier les familles chez eux
principalement dans leur salon on a
choisi de recréer un salon un petit peu
hybride dans lequel en fait les gens
vont retrouver un petit peu les
empreintes nostalgiques et les cadeaux
c'est toujours intéressant de se
replonger dans les dents les objets
comme ça qui ont fait partie de notre
quotidien d'avant ces objets d'ailleurs
on les a principalement entre vennes à
husky
qui sait offre de conservation le livre
de jean-françois ça me long sur cette
exposition sortira d'ici en moi vue
intérieure sera présenté à l'artothèque
jusqu'au 28 février 2016